pascal blanchet chef du service urologie
du centre hospitalier universitaire de
guadeloupe
devant un parterre de scientifiques et
de journalistes il présente des
résultats de l'étude karuprostate 1500
individus de plus de 30 ans choisies
dans la population guadeloupéenne
et toujours pas de preuve formelle que
la chlordécone est la cause du cancer de
la prostate
les études épidémiologiques elle arrive
toujours à trouver des liens
statistiques
donc il ya une association après dé dire
que c'est une lien lien causal évident
c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
difficile
déjà les études ému et épidémiologiques
montrent que
ça ne provoque pas le cancer c'est pas
un initiateur de l'action se résume à
sion c'est une promotion c'est à dire il
faut déjà que y ait des cellules
cancéreuses qui soient présentes pour
que la chlordécone puisse agir
mais ces mêmes scientifiques estiment
qu'on peut raisonnablement considérer la
chlordécone comme facteur de risque
supplémentaire
l'étude karuprostate démontre notamment
que le risque de cancer de la prostate
froid avec le taux de chlordécone dans
le sang et que le temps de résidence de
la molécule dans le corps est un facteur
aggravant
chez le rat il a été démontré que la
prostate absorbé plus facilement la
chlordécone que d'autres organes
exception faite du froid on a d'abord
montré que le tissu prostatique accumulé
la chlordécone de façon plus importante
que d'autres tissus
c'était le foie mais qu'en plus les
tissu prostatique un séreux les no deal
quand serait à l'intérieur des prostate
accumuler sur accumulé la chlordécone
dans les nodules à minima la corde et
comme serait donc un facteur aggravant
favorisant le développement du cancer de
la prostate quel en sera responsable
reste encore à démontrer
on a mis très longtemps à reconnaître
que le tabac était
facteur de risque pour le cancer du
poumon alors vous imaginez des nuances
sémantiques qui freinent encore la
reconnaissance d'éventuelles
responsabilités dans ce que le président
de la république lui même a bien voulu
reconnaître comme étant un scandale
environnemental mais pas sanitaires